la souffrance très peu pour moi j'ai
goûté c'est bon
et bien d'autres
si on veut vraiment terminer ce portrait
de la nouvelle Lara Fabian je pense que
on va montrer votre côté obscur
s'appelera aux arbres cultivent les Rama
vous voyez le côté voilà le côté un peu
un peu détruit comme ça
obscur
est-ce que vous picolez toute seule non
est-ce que vous prenez régulièrement de
la drogue jamais est-ce que vous aimez
le contact des armes à feu
j'en ai jamais tenu dans ma main j'ai
déjà volé dans un magasin jamais vous
arrachez les cheveux parfois
si vous avez déjà essayé de vous mutiler
la souffrance très peu pour moi j'ai
goûté c'est bon
vous avez déjà pensé au suicide
quand on y pense c'est pas forcément la
pensée n'est pas corrélée à l'acte mais
ouais j'ai pensé une fois
j'ai envie de tuer quelqu'un non avant
de vous suicider
de la chair humaine
un petit peu plus oui un peu plus dark
un peu plus marrer
les cicatrices ça vous excite
sur les mains d'un homme je trouve ça
très joli noire
ça
c'est
basé un enfant
[Applaudissements]
non
parce qu'il me voilà
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait l'amour
dans un lieu public
comme toutes les mamans voilà
je sais que je les ai surpris quand
j'étais petit
de vos parents
on est d'accord
faire l'amour j'étais obligé carrément
quand on est en vacances
vous êtes déjà fait filmer en train de
faire l'amour là
avec Baffie non est-ce que vous êtes
déjà partagé votre copain avec une
copine
et puis vous lui dire
on va lui donner les fiches vous avez
déjà fait l'amour en membres impair
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait couler de
la cire sur le corps de votre science
et dernière question évidemment la plus
importante
regardez-moi bien dans soyez sincère
même si la dernière fois de votre vie
est-ce que vous avez déjà sucé le pied
d'un homme
j'étais aussi un petit peu méchant
et non jamais et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu